Monday night's 5.8 magnitude earthquake...
...shook not only the southwestern part of Korea close to the epicenter,...
...but also Seoul and other parts of the country.
The Korea Meteorological Administration...
...said that this quake's actual waveform was very extensive,...
...so much so that it spread throughout the nation.
The strongest earthquake prior to the one on Monday night...
...was a 5.3 magnitude quake that occurred in Euiju,...
...Pyongan-bukdo province, in North Korea in 1980.
The Korean Peninsula has been relatively safe from earthquakes...
...since it is located away from the edge of a tectonic plate.
Nonetheless, experts predict that the country could be hit...
...by an earthquake as strong as 6.5 magnitude.